ce n'est pas juste portait un drapeau il
y a le poids de l'histoire d'une mémoire
qui se perpétue la solennité d'une
cérémonie millimétré lourd à porter pour
un enfant de 14 ans pas forcément pour
guillaume 1 c'est comme si cela coulait
de source six ans déjà que ce bisontin
participe aux cérémonies du 11 novembre
comme porte drapeau lui qui rêve de
devenir militaire 7 transmettre la
mémoire surtout pour honorer la mémoire
de ma famille que dans le film on a une
longue histoire militaire je suis fier
de le porter
chiche content quand je le porte c'est
un peu comme s'ils portaient un peu leur
mémoire au moins comme ça on se souvient
de et hautmont bas comme ça jamais dans
l'oubli là où parfois l'idée vient des
parents c'est ici tout l'inversé c'est
guillaume qui a convaincu son père de se
mobiliser avec lui je pense que les gens
ne s'intéressent mais que les parents
qui n'intéressent pas les jeunes et
les personnes de mon âge n'applique pas
assez leurs enfants dans la transmission
de mémoire un coup de jeune qui rassure
les plus âgés toujours mobilisés aux
côtés
mais dans la tente de la relève
c'est bien c'est bien 15 ans et courbe
et est un honneur a des fois c'est pas
marrant des fois il pleut
il fait très chaud nous aurons bientôt
partir or le devoir de mémoire il faut
qu'ils continuent quand je vois des
petites équipes qui prennent la relève
qui sont prêts ça nous enchante nous et
puis cela nous permet de rester jeune
mais les jeunes comme guillaume reste
encore trop rare ce sont pourtant eux
qui devront se mobiliser pour perpétuer
l'engagement de leurs aînés pour ne pas
oublier ceux qui se sont battus pour la
liberté